[Musique]
les shadoks sont sauvés il arrive sur la
terre au fur et à mesure qu'ils
approchaient leur joie grandissait
quelques uns aiment moururent de joie
avant d'arriver et un beau matin il
atterrit fait il ressortir de l'autre
côté mais plus mouillé car évidemment il
s'était trompé
ce n'était pas la terre qu'ils avaient
là mais ce qu'on appelait autrefois la
planète à eau
la planète à eau étaient une planète
ronde est normal et sauf qu'elle était
faite exclusivement dont il y avait de
l'eau ou de l'eau on va nm de l'eau au
milieu les arbres là où il y en avait
était évidemment obligé de nager ça
faisait de très jolis forêt aquatique
qui tenait debout sur l'eau avec eux
rien en dessous
[Musique]
[Rires]
et les poissons volants qui étaient les
seuls habitants de la planète
venez dans leurs branches pour se
reposer et s'amuser les shadoks eux ne
s'amusait pas du tout ils passaient leur
temps sous l'eau car ils étaient
persuadés qu'ils étaient sur la tête et
il essayait de la tournée il le chercher
pendant assez longtemps
puis un jour le devin poulpe puisque la
terre était par en dessous
il disait qu'il fallait simplement
prendre l'eau et la mettre à côté et que
lui avec son robinet magique et quelques
shadoks volontaire il on ferait son
affaire
[Musique]